so so I'll give you a little overview of
what I'll talk about here as an aside I
given this talk in different forms in
the past this year but it's been kind of
different because the audience was a
little different after speaking with the
conference organizers and getting some
feedback about this talk from people in
kind of the things that they wanted to
you know the messages they wanted the
sort of things that they were interested
in hearing I decided to change the way
that I do this so if you happen to watch
a version of this talk at Microsoft
build or something like that then you're
going to see something different today
even though I guess some of the basics
are still going to be there so I think
I'll start with a little overview of
f-sharp the language and ecosystem
tooling like all that sort of stuff so
you get a decent holistic idea of what f
sharp is all about today then I'll talk
a little bit about F sharp usage kind of
across the world after having spoken
with multiple customers just open-source
developers all that sort of stuff and
and I learned a lot about how people are
using F sharp not only in their day to
day work but you know even including
side projects and I wanted to share some
of that I'll talk a little bit about how
Microsoft thinks about F sharp
strategically so that this is really
getting into the nitty-gritty of kind of
why F sharp that's hopefully a
convincing story to tell and then I want
to talk a little bit about how f sharp
stacks up with other functional
programming languages hopefully that
part is not too controversial I I tend
to think that I'm objective in
evaluating different languages because I
like languages as a whole so if
something is rather controversial well
hopefully it doesn't get too many people
angry so basic overview of F sharp let's
talk about some facts because facts are
great I like facts so it's functional
program for dotnet it's there's you
write functional programming code for
dotnet in F sharps that's this I mean
like there's I've thought about kind of
how I want to describe that sharp in the
past so you know it's like this
functional first language it's got
object blah blah blah and like nothing
really fit other than its functional
programming for net there are other ways
that you can do functional programming
for net you can
you see sharp but you're probably not
going to have as good of a time as if
you just went with F sharp anyways so
that's just really the the most
important bit it also adds
object-oriented capabilities so you can
write F sharp code using objects to
interoperate with the rest of net to
interoperate with another library that's
very object-oriented heavy and you can
sort of say okay well I'm going to use
oh oh to you know deal with what I need
to deal with and then call into a very
functional kernel if you will in the
rest of my F sharp code and kind of be a
sort of hybrid functional and oh oh but
but kind of it's unlike other languages
where there's like a very distinct
separation between the OO and the
functional we sort of try to blend
things a little bit and take the bits of
oo that actually are functional and say
no no this is part of functional
programming and this is something that
you can embrace okay F sharp is part of
the.net core SDK that is to say if you
have dotnet core installed on your
machine today you have F sharp already
on your machine today there's no special
button you need to click somewhere
there's no special download you just
already have it if you don't have dotnet
core on your machine I suggest you go
ahead and get it because it's pretty
cool and it's it's you know it didn't
just you know accidentally fall in there
like oh whoops is that sharp in there
like it's it's a very deliberate
decision I'm gonna talk about that a
little bit more as the talk goes on F
sharp runs everywhere just by virtue of
being on net I mean you can do Windows
apps and on a framework kind of as
existing f sharp developers have likely
done for quite a long time already
xamarin forms amber and iOS and xamarin
Android you can just do it and I don't
really know how else to say it and then
there's templates there's tooling
support it all works you can just do it
it's fun and there's dotnet core and ASP
net core support for F sharp and there
are multiple libraries that sit on top
of asp.net core depending on the flavor
of web server programming that you want
to do and I think that's rather
important because very recently asp.net
core broke the top ten and tech and
power benchmarks and the team is very
focused on making it a highly performant
web stack and so as a result of just
just being on asp.net core and being
part of dotnet core F sharp you it's
it's a language that you can use to
write highly performant web servers
that's just a thing that you can do now
which is
fantastic so I want to talk a little bit
about what-what I tried to reduce down
into what I think are the the most key
aspects of what f-sharp programming is
all about cuz there there's there I mean
there's a bunch of different features
there's a bunch of different things that
you can do with the language and some
are interesting for some people some are
not that interesting for some people but
there's there's actually really only two
things that I everybody does with
f-sharp and the first one is you use
types to model data if that's kind of an
obvious statement right I mean you do
that an object-oriented programming as
well but it's a little different I mean
if I wanted to very poorly model the
domain of a withdrawal from a bank
account I could create a type called a
successful withdrawal that is just an
aggregate of you know in amounts in this
case a decimal and you know whatever the
balance was and what's interesting is
this isn't like like an object in
c-sharp or Java where I then need to
think about Oh what other oo isms do I
have to put on here so I can do things
like default equality or be able to
compare things really easily or you know
oftentimes especially in like the
distributed scenario you want things to
be immutable and like it's it's kind of
nice to have things to be immutable by
default which you can't really do in
some of these object-oriented
programming languages which is the
default here right this is a record type
where it's immutable its default
equatable and its default comparable and
it just has some values inside of it and
there's honestly not much more to it
which which is what I really really love
about this because it's just a such a
straightforward mapping between
something that could happen and how
you're gonna represent it in a way and
then you could have a failed withdrawal
that could just have a bit more in there
in this case and a mount balance and if
I potentially overdraft it and so I
guess in this case I set my bank account
up such that if I were to overdraft then
it would fail there's lots of different
ways you could tweak this I'm not a
domain modeler and then there's this
other type which is called a
discriminated union type where I can say
okay well I'm gonna try to withdraw
something and I could come back a number
of different ways right it could succeed
and then I
that you know I've might withdrawal cool
that's nice but I could not have enough
money in which case that's this failed
withdrawal that I'd have called here you
know there could be multiple types of
failures that can occur right like if I
was drew with a card maybe my cards
expired so like you know it's obviously
not going to withdraw like I mean for a
financial system like this you're
probably going to have 20 maybe even 30
different cases of things that can occur
but kind of what I what I really like
about this is how it's just one line
maps to one case and it's a very
succinct way of sort of dealing with the
fact that information is it could be
coming in multiple forms and you want to
have a rep represent that in a very type
safe way if you were to try to do this
in c-sharp or Java you'd be writing a
lot of code and that code would probably
be very error-prone it probably wouldn't
be the nicest to write because it's just
this this sort of modeling of saying
okay I want to have some aggregate data
and then I want to have data that could
represent multiple different forms it's
just not something that those type
systems were set up to do and and that's
and as it turns out just in standard
everyday programming these are common
problems that people have and so this is
why it's it's it's so ubiquitous
throughout all I've start programming
and so this is the first key element of
F start programming the second one is
just some functions that act on the data
right so in this case if I want to
handle a withdrawal I want to say okay I
wanna withdraw this amount of money do
the withdrawal it gives me a results
that I then needed to deal with right
many other languages you would have to
special you would have to know to like
put the if state if statement like
everywhere and if you have a junior
programmer who may not necessarily be
aware of like the complexity of a given
domain because they just haven't been
there long enough or something like that
they may miss an if statement somewhere
and there's nothing in the language that
would tell them like you know hey you
didn't account for all possible cases
here this is another critical thing this
is pattern matching and if you're
familiar with c-sharp pattern matching
just imagine that it has more
functionality and that it's better and
that's basically what this is doing
and and yes f-sharp has inspired c-sharp
pattern matching so far so because we've
had it before so in this case our the
the gist of what's going on here is just
saying okay well there's a results and I
want to act on that data based on the
shape of that data right so I took my
data I modeled it with types like a
really powerful type system and then I
go in and I say all right now I'm going
to dispatch functionality based on the
way that the data is actually formed
this is if you're coming from a
dynamically typed language your code
might actually look fairly similar to
this like in JavaScript you can just say
oh well it's just you know this object
it's got this stuff on there but in that
sort of land you don't have the type
safety so you know something could go
wrong at some point during you know who
knows when and then all of a sudden your
code won't work anymore well in this
case because it's strongly typed you
actually get the compile time stuff and
so kind of the whole model with types
records and discriminated unions and
then add functions that act on that data
that's represented this types and
pattern matching on that data makes up
almost every single if not every single
like actual fully formed F chart program
out there from the biggest systems to
just the smallest aside projects like
this is just this is just what you do
and you know I was thinking about if I
should go into other DIF interesting
techniques that you could apply here
like functional composition or higher
order functions or something like that
but honestly that's not even necessary
for writing good F sharp code really you
just take the type you just take some
types that you use to model data and
that itself is an art form I guess and
then you just you just act on it with
functions and it's super easy and F
sharp and you can go a really really
long way just with these two core
concepts and I want people who are you
know new to F sharp to sort of feel that
that's really all that they need to know
to get started and you can you can I
mean you can build your own DSL with
this for example so it's it's pretty
powerful but that's not the only thing
that f sharp is about I mentioned the
auro stuff and the reality is that F
sharp lives on dotnet dotnet was built
with c-sharp c-sharp is an
object-oriented programming language
dotnet has object-oriented
trucks inside of it and you have to
interact with that in some way but more
to the point that's it's it's not it's
not even just dealing with that reality
that you know explains why we have
object orientated ease but you know
sometimes you may actually want to do
something with objects that are not
easily represented in a record or
discriminated union right so you know
you can put attributes on stuff that's
that's fairly straightforward you know
you can use the sealed attribute if you
use that in c-sharp it does exactly what
you think it does compiled name does
probably exactly what you think it does
it just gives it a name so in the
assembly that's what it's actually
called and then you have another type
declaration but in this case it's a bit
more complicated because maybe you want
to do something that is a bit more
intricate in nature this is where
objects can really come in handy in this
case this is actually taken from the F
sharp core library source itself we have
a set type and it's sealed it has a
compiled name and then we have a type
parameter that we have another attribute
on and then we were find that type
parameter by saying yes well it takes in
it you know you can have a set of T when
T is comparable okay this is I think
what people would normally associate
with being object-oriented but it's it's
objects it's more just object
programming so much as object oriented
because everything that I'm sewing so
far starts showing so far is actually
really functional right so there's a
constructor you know new given some
elements that is a sequence of type T
produce a set of type T right where T is
that refined you know T that that's
comparable there that's entirely
functional right you can have a method
called add these are type signatures by
the way a method called add that you
know given a value which is of type T
produce a set of type T which is
basically saying I'll have a set I'm
going to add a value to it well that's
actually a different set right it's a
set that contains another value so it is
conceptually event thing now under the
covers you know there's like you know
this is an immutable data structure
that's implemented with you know trees
and stuff to kind of swap out nodes and
things like that so it's efficient but
this is this is the way that you reason
about it because you know it's not add
an element to a thing and thus change
the thing in place it's adding an
element to a thing produces a new thing
and that's it and you can you can
accomplish this with object-oriented
constructs but still stay completely
func
so a whole bunch more methods but I
didn't bother showing them you can do
interface implementation like this and
interfaces are you know again actually a
very functional concept this is just
saying here's a contract where you know
I have this functionality and they say
oh I'm gonna implement this
functionality and then other callers can
just deal with you know interfaces in
that sort of contract based way this is
usually the way that you communicate
across assembly boundaries in dotnet
anyways or at least I guess the way that
you're supposed to do it and that's just
the that's the viewpoint that we take
with F sharp as well except you can
communicate with other F sharp
components this way too like you know
this isn't just for interoperating with
some c-sharp code or you know some API
that requires an interface or something
like that in this case set apparently
has five interface implementations which
is pretty cool so you can do it like
that and we have lovely overrides
because we want to change the way that
equality default equality works in this
case another thing that's interesting
about classes because this is this is
just a class right and you know the the
implementation is Alita but you can sort
of understand kind of what the general
structure is just by looking at the
signature it's there they're a bit
different in that so they cannot be
assigned no by default I need to
actually decorate it with an attribute
called allowing the literal so that this
whole knowability sort of thing has just
already baked in there also when you
bind it to a value you say you know let
x equals you know you know construct a
new sets or something like that X is
immutable by default you cannot change X
itself you have to actually declare it
as mutable if you want to do that now
because it is a class you can't have
mutable values inside of the class that
you could mutate in place and so forth
but that's that's like an opt-in sort of
thing right we want you to sort of opt
in to things like mutability and
changing things in place which could
potentially complicate a program but we
want to extract all the good bits of
object programming and say this is
functional too it's just got maybe some
different syntax than other languages
would you know consider something like
that so you use oo and it makes sense an
F sharp in you know that yeah and like
you don't do it like in contrast
- modeling types with data and acting on
that data with functions you know you do
it - well you do it want to make sense
sometimes you need to do something
that's a bit more complicated but you
can still stay functional and I think
this is kind of the rounding out sort of
the spirit of a sharp programming and
guidance for this is entirely documented
so this is a cute little short URL aka
MS f-sharp style guide this is an
official style guide that sort of
documents some of this stuff and much
much more detailed stuff too but you
know kind of a whole point of that is if
you're learning f-sharp and you you you
you're working with a construct and then
you say oh well am I using this
construct in a good way
basically this guide is supposed to
answer that question for you and so you
can something that you can bookmark and
refer to as you kind of go on your
functional programming journey something
that I'm particularly proud about with
this is this is built in collaboration
with customers and other open source
contributors who have large code bases
in F sharp who have had years of
experience dealing with lots of
different features and then basically
being able to say hey guess what we use
this feature and it totally sucked we
should totally not do this at all and
that that was based off of F sharp in
the large solving hard problems it's
also an evolving set of documents so
it's entirely open source we welcome any
contributions and additional questions
to it and if you read it if you're an
experienced F sharp developer you read
it and you say I hate everything about
this this this says out all the wrong
stuff
well because it's open source you can
actually you know give us that feedback
and we can have a discussion about that
sort of stuff and so I would definitely
watch this if you're new to F sharp
because it's going to be continually
evolving and more things are going to be
added right so another another
interesting bit about F sharp is that it
has truly ubiquitous tooling and I don't
mean that in the sense of every tooling
vendor or open source contributor you
know creates their own version of the
compiler that mimics F sharp semantics
you know as best as they can the F sharp
compiler itself you know very
similar to Rosalyn actually is a
compiler that has AP eyes and those AP
eyes are part of what's called the
f-sharp compiler service and that's
what's used by editors everywhere
including Visual Studio okay so visual
studios had f-sharp support for quite a
while but that's not the only one that
you have - well it's not the only way
for you to get F sharp programming into
your date with work Visual Studio for
Mac also installs F sharp by default
Visual Studio code anion ID R so I
Knight is it's a community plugin but
it's like the official F sharp plugin
for writing a short code in Visual
Studio code if you're the kind of person
who just prefers a lighter-weight text
editor but all of the features of an IDE
without the you know the big
installation size of an IDE you can get
this it's really really cool it's
actually it's a community technical
initiative that just really took off and
is flourished I think into something
that thousands of people love using
every single day okay
there's Donna CLI support for F sharp
because that comes in the.net course UK
if you're in the business of you know
making builds work on a build server
well there you go that's how you do it
it's real easy JetBrains Rider they're
actually here today I recommend checking
them out they install f-sharp by default
as well so if you want to see what
that's all about you can do that too and
the thing that's great about each of
these editors including them is kind of
as I said that they're using the same
compiler and the same compiler api's so
you know this isn't as I said one person
going in and implementing you know some
subset of f-sharp semantics and building
tools around it this is actually the
same core component and this is I think
unique across all functional programming
languages I think every other language
for you know tooling vendors and open
source contributors they sort of build
their own compiler effectively and it's
sometimes not the same compiler as what
gets built bundled up with their build
tools and that can that can lead to some
confusion that's just not a thing in fer
p-- which which is which is phenomenal
so another really cool thing that I've
sharp it runs on the web and I don't
mean like on a web server I mean
literally on the web there's this
amazing project out there called fable
if you value github stars like you value
currency
than fable is just as important as F
sharp itself because it has like the
same amount of stars it's pretty cool
it's an F sharp to JavaScript compiler
where it just takes the F sharp syntax
tree and then it uses it converts it
into a babel syntax tree so if you're
familiar at all with babel it's it's
it's a really good way to write modern
JavaScript and have it run and way more
browsers this is this is what it does
and then it also supports j/s native
Interop so like if you need to
interoperate with a thing that you know
is literally there in JavaScript like
you can do that it's it's actually
conceptually somewhat similar to like P
invoke and stuff it's it's it's
fantastic this this is an entirely open
source initiative and the goal was to
create a viable JavaScript alternative
and they have accomplished that goal
which is absolutely great you can use
the entire NPM ecosystem for this so you
can write your f sharp code to literally
replace JavaScript you can include any
library that you want you can consume
typescript definition files because
maybe one of your co-workers as a
typescript fan you can produce
typescript definition files so you can
give them stuff right you can use react
and redux tools and like you can do the
whole like you know message based UI
stuff and then do time travel debugging
and and and source maps with chrome like
all of that is supported it literally
shows that sharpen the source map it's
it's incredible that I didn't mention
here but there's hot module reloading
too so you can just have a piece of F
sharp code that you change and then when
you save it it doesn't you know rebuild
the entire Dom it just builds that
little piece that you actually changed
it's it's incredible there's another way
that you can do F sharp on the web
called web sharper which has been around
for a lot longer and it has slightly
different goals its goal is to be a full
stack functional reactive programming
framework for F sharp and also C sharp
that is basically built on dotnet core I
think their goals have changed over time
because I think they're on web sharper
version for but you know it runs in the
browser as well and you can you can use
that to run on react native and have it
run on the phones and things like that
and it's a commercial product with
commercial support so if that's the sort
of thing that that you're interested in
I definitely remand recommend checking
it out fable dot IO I didn't mention
this it has a repple so you can actually
play around with it in the
it's one of the coolest things ever so
I'm really excited about it
f-sharp also runs in adjure or any cloud
that's not sure I guess but yeah it runs
an adder yeah
it's fully supported and Azure functions
which is a big deal because that's
something that we really care a lot
about fragile moving forward it's kind
of been there almost really from the
get-go
you know the portal based script based
stuff it's been there for quite a long
time it's still there it works just
great
you can do compiled library style stuff
with v2 add your functions there's a
little bit of work that we have to do to
light up the templates in Visual Studio
that's on our roadmap it's just not
there yet but you know you can use the
dotnet CLI to create one of these things
and you can go ahead and publish it a
sure it all works there's also a new
functions programming model called
durable functions that's it's very much
in pre-release right now but it's gonna
definitely transform the service and
there's already a community effort to
build an F sharp programming model
around that when you're using F sharp
for it it uses a feature of F sharp
called computation expressions and it's
it's beautiful beautiful programming
model so that's something to look out
for as your notebooks is another thing
that's powered by an AF sharp kernel so
if you're familiar with ipython kernels
or I think there's a nice collar kernel
ijs kernel something like that this is
interactive it's just an interactive
programming environment for the browser
using Jupiter notebooks and it's a
really great tool for beginners we
actually have a template that you can do
which is an introduction to f-sharp so
if you don't have anything installed in
your machine except for a browser you
can use that today and then you can
share the Jupiter notebooks that you
produce with other people so it uses
just like a get based model and so you
can fork and you know clone different
things and so forth and you can do that
all in F sharp which is really cool and
then all other services where dotnet
runs F sharp runs as well and it's fully
supported because it's a dotnet language
right dotnet is the first-class citizen
and Azure therefore F sharp is a
first-class citizen and Azure so this is
really important because Asher is quite
important for the future of Microsoft so
it makes me happy so that was an
overview of kind of how I'm framing up F
sharp like modern
sharp today the way the way it exists I
want to talk a little bit about where
it's used because one thing that I hear
from a lot of people is oh but what
would I use F sharp for who uses F sharp
what do they do with it like that sort
of thing well I'll talk first about how
it's used in the industry and then I'll
talk about how it's used within
Microsoft so in industry one of our
largest customers is jet comm you can
read their tech blog they have a whole
bunch F sharp stuff on there it's pretty
cool they have hundreds of F sharp
engineers building a state-of-the-art
ecommerce system like literally hundreds
and they they're like taking over this
building that they're in when they used
to be a start-up now they're just like
booting people out of the building
because they're growing so fast and they
they have a massive F sharp codebase
implementing all sorts of really cool
stuff and they attribute a lot of their
success from growing from just a tiny
startup to a really big growing business
to their use of F sharp and doing
literally what I showed just modeling
complex data with types and then acting
on that with functions that's I mean
they use some other advanced features
and stuff too but fundamentally that's
all that they're doing and they're able
to see a lot of success with that
janna tech is another company that's
been using F sharp for quite a long time
there are large IOT solutions companies
so I'm not sure if they have F sharp
running on the IOT devices but they do
have it on like their you know
management services that sort of deal
with all the different types of devices
that could go in the different protocols
that are coming over the wire and stuff
like that well again they sort of model
a lot of that data with types and F
sharp and they're able to implement
things for the different IOT devices
they have very very rapidly and it's
been quite a maintainable thing for them
so NRK if you're familiar with that
certainly here in the audience largest
media organization in Norway they have
multiple teams using F sharp I just
visited with them yesterday and it was
it was a great time there they're
growing there they're hiring you know
you know at least they've certainly
hired new F star programmers and it's
they've seen a lot of success with using
F sharp to manage some of their TV
services I believe in radio services as
well and then there's many smaller
organizations worldwide there's also
some bigger ones like some banks that I
don't know if they're okay with being
mentioned that they use a technology so
I'm just not gonna mention them but it's
using the finance and
a lot it's used and you know financial
modeling statistical modeling data
science you know just mom-and-pop web
apps like you know just be everything
from what you would consider complex
systems to just kind of everyday create
read update delete systems f-sharp is
used from organizations large and small
speaking of large organizations it's
also used in Microsoft so and it's used
in a few places
so f-sharp came from Microsoft Research
that's where it was born and thus it has
quite a bit of usage there they have a
lot of different teams using it for
different research projects and then we
also have multiple data science teams at
Microsoft that also use F sharp for some
of their data science efforts like with
an office Windows Azure and so forth
it's actually a personal quest of mine
over the next year or so is to reach out
to other data science teams and sort of
see if F sharp would make sense for some
of the problems that they may encounter
we have a product called Microsoft
security risk detection it used to be
called Project Springfield this used to
be an MSR project but it's it's it's
grown into a full product it's basically
they do fuzz detection as a service yeah
fuzzing as a service and so you just
basically upload you know parts of your
application you say I want you to beat
this thing to death and tell me where
every single possible issue could arise
from a security perspective and then
they do that
the fuzzer I believe is written in C++
but the actual product is written in F
sharp and they were very deliberate
about that they started from the
beginning they said you know this is
going to be a service running and Azure
this is a distributed system because
it's a distributed system we like to
have less surprises so immutable by
default is a good way to have less
surprises about your data and they just
kind of went from there and they've been
very successful in onboarding new
engineers who knew nothing about F sharp
and just growing their their products
from like a research thing into a fully
fledged product that we now sell people
and Azure which is pretty cool
there's the notes and tasks team at
Microsoft so some of the products that
they own are OneNote and Windows sticky
notes they they're an interesting group
there are very polyglot groups
you know they use lots of different
languages but a lot of them in
particular our fans of functional
programming and they needed to do some
stuff with net and they're like hey well
we want to do FP on net so let's just
use F sharp and specifically the team
that is using it and also hiring by the
way is is I think it's called the notes
fabric team or the notes and tasks
fabric basically what they do is they're
sort of like a sync layer between
multiple different applications like you
know one note when these sticky notes
Microsoft to do wonder list various
to-do items that you can have on
different versions of exchange going
back to like 2008 or something like that
there's a lot of complex problems in
syncing information across all you know
these different data formats and these
different applications running in
different environments and they they
chose f-sharp and while functional
programming specifically deliberately to
do that and they wanted to use F sharp
and they wanted to do on that and
they've been quite successful with it to
the point where they're hiring so it's
pretty cool there's a group with an
azure that dozen Amelie detection so
that well they're kind of a data science
team but they also have a little web
service that they built it's I guess
it's more of an internal tool more than
anything else but it's just they wanted
to throw up a quick web service to sort
of report information about the
different models that they run on Azure
usage so that when they see a spike they
can determine with some likelihood if
you know if it was actual usage from a
customer or if it was an anomaly and and
you know you know not make sure not to
build this person for something that
they didn't do I would argue that's a
rather important port of the Microsoft
business that is F sharp is highly
involved in this it's so it's something
you could tell your boss I guess
and lastly thing that I work on my pride
and joy the F sharp compiler and the
tools for Visual Studio are also
implemented entirely in F sharp except
for the little C sharp v6 project I
think that we have and we have like some
template stuff and Visual Basic but it's
really all F sharp so that's at least as
far as I know what people do primarily
with F sharper than Microsoft there are
some personal projects there are some
smaller tools and things like that that
there
teams use I guess they just weren't big
enough or noteworthy to call out here
so speaking of Microsoft and f-sharp I
said that I would give a little bit of a
view into sort of how we think about F
sharp strategically well that's this
part right here as a side note when I
went and build and I drank some some
water I think it's like minute 35 or
something like that there was a really
just like glug here sounding here I I
hope that does not happen again so we
have a very very basic viewpoint for F
sharp I mean it's this light could
honestly just be this single bullet
point the way that we think about it is
that it is ought to be and should
forever be the most productive
functional programming language on the
market what productive means is kind of
up to you some people care about tools
some people care about the speed of the
compiler some people care about the
speed of the runtime some people care
about the different abstractions that
are available some people care about if
they're able to hire for it like you
know product productive can mean
anything really but you know where it's
it's intentionally general and perhaps
vague on purpose because it's it's
really about the sum of the parts my F
sharp is not just about having a
particular thing in this type system
it's not just about having some tools
that are really good you know it's not
just about having a compiler that's
faster than the scholars compiler like
that's right but all of the all of these
things you know there may be one area
where one particular language or
environment does something better and
there may be an area where we do
something the best like it's it's and
that and that can change over time right
and but the way that we look at it is
well if you aggregate everything that
people typically think of being
productive with a programming language
we want that aggregate to feel like it's
the greatest than f-sharp and if it's
not then we want to work to make that
true okay
we think it's integral it's an integral
part of dotnet future this is well kind
of as I said you know it wasn't by
accident that f-sharp is in the dotnet
it's decay didn't just you know
/ and just hop in like that's it's part
of dot Nets future where we're trying to
expand the reach of dotnet beyond the
realm of Windows and f-sharp is a part
of that simply right and that that's
just how we view it we think it's a
great choice for cloud programming kind
of as I mentioned when you're doing
things with just distributed systems you
tend to not like surprises and you get
more surprises when your data is mutable
by defaults or at least the the
programming language in which you model
your data is mutable by default right we
are immutable by defaults so you get
less surprises and that's pretty good
and in the distributed environment where
things are so hairy anyways okay we view
F sharp as innovating in language design
and tools alright and this isn't to say
that c-sharp is not we view c-sharp is
doing this as well but F sharp does it
in a different way
I mentioned computation expressions
earlier it's it's this beautiful way to
represent you know what a Haskell
programmer may call monadic composition
or something like that but really what
it's all about is there can be a a kind
of domain level context in which code
needs to execute and that context may
not be as straightforward as just a
single threaded
you know straightforward thing and like
for example in the F sharp tools for
visual studio
well actually sorry not for visual
studio in the estro compiler service
there's a notion of something being
cancelable because you can have a
potentially long-running operation and
you may want to cue up another operation
that needs to run and that might be more
important like you know coloring up a
document that you right-click open while
another operation was happening well you
don't want to have that document fail to
open and show colors and stuff while a
long-running thing is going on so we
want to be able to represent the notion
of a potentially long-running
computation that can be canceled at some
point in time and superseded by another
one the way that that's implemented is
with a language feature that allows you
to do so in a type safe and really
beautiful and maintainable way and then
on the tooling side of that with the
forthcoming F sharp 4.5 release that's
going to be coming out later this this
summer or perhaps in the fall we'll see
where we're doing some work to tool this
sort of stuff a little bit better
specifically with the asynchronous
computation expression that we have and
you know produce better stack traces
from this sort of stuff because there's
language design and then there's tooling
that surrounds a particular feature or
set of features and we view that as part
of innovation as well because c-sharp
went and did an amazing set of things
with async stack traces but they have a
totally different model for asynchronous
computation than we do
even though fundamentally it's doing the
same thing it's it's a thing called a
hot task model whereas we have a cold
task model
well the question of how do you tool
something like a cold task model is
something that we innovate in and we we
feel that this is really important not
just for you know the language f-sharp
but for the dotnet ecosystem as well
it's an area where this stuff can happen
this we also view it as a place to
innovate in mobile development there's
been a bit of a recent surge and want to
do functional reactive programming or
you know this thing called Model View
update for phone you eyes and people can
use react native for that today while
we're doing some work to build a model
like that for xamarin based development
so that if you want to do that for
mobile development we're going to have
that available in F sharp 2 and lastly
and perhaps one of the most important
things is we have an innovative
community right they they start
incredible technical initiatives you
know not all of them succeed but that's
fine I mean you know for innovation you
need to experiment you need to see
what's going on but some of those really
stick like iein I'd you know in an IDE
without the baggage of an IDE inside a
Visual Studio code incredible fable like
being able to run F sharp coherently in
a in a browser and be able to use all
the JavaScript based tools this is
something that they do and they're
they're very driven individuals in the
community and it's it's a it's
infectious people who come in and
they're new they may not have had a you
know a history of contributing to open
source and then they get excited about
that because everybody else in the F
sharp community is excited about that
and then people do things like in the
version that's going to be coming up
after our four point five one of the new
language features was implemented
entirely by a brand new community member
he hadn't been you know he actually came
in later this year sorry actually
earlier this year and he created an
issue on github for our language
suggestions repository which is
and source and then we all sort of said
yeah this is a good idea
he created the RFC for you know the
actual spec of what this is gonna be and
then he wrote the feature in the
compiler and then he collaborated with
us and with other members in the
community to figure out like what the
best error messages and things like that
and then it got merged and and that's
this is a brand new person came in and
like there's stories like this all over
the place in the f-sharp community and
they're keen on collaborating with
Microsoft to like they don't feel like
they're this isolated group of people
who have to do stuff despite you know
some corporation taking the thing that
they love in some other direction you
know they want to see not only other
people in the community succeed succeed
but they want to see Microsoft succeed
as well and this is really important and
they're also very happy to let us know
when we do something poorly which is
extremely valuable actually like a you
know that smiley face is not a sarcastic
one like it's often times you can get
caught up in your bubble trying to build
something and you don't really see the
forest for the trees and sometimes it
just takes an active community member
who really knows what they're doing to
tell you to stop and the f-chart
community are willing to do this sort of
thing which is incredibly valuable so we
have a few core tenants about the
language I guess is how I'm calling it
this is somewhat similar to how we view
F sharp there but I guess a slightly
refined version of that right F sharp is
a part of dotnet and F sharp evolves as
dotnet evolves alright so that doesn't
mean that net you know grabs F sharp and
just drags it along screaming or
something like that you know it's a
collaborative effort where F sharp
innovates in a certain way that that
feeds into dotnet dotnet moves in that
direction particularly as far as the
community is concerned the F sharp F
sharp has always had an incredible
community and this is something that
dotnet as a whole has always sought and
it's you know within net there is
actually an example of how to do things
which is pretty great f sharp runs well
on Azure is one of our core tenants and
that means if there's an issue with F
sharp running well on Azure today it's
something that's going to be prioritized
and fixed because we want it to run well
on Azure F sharp innovates in many ways
like you know it not just in language
features but also on how you two of
those language features
it f-sharp as a whole you know not just
the Microsoft employees working on I've
sharp but F sharp also innovates in the
community space I think right F sharp
revolves steadily and prioritizes
stability and predictability I'm gonna
talk about this a little bit more
shortly but basically what this means is
that as we evolved the F sharp language
by you know adding new features or
something like that people in the
community should not feel surprised you
know at a new feature coming along or
something like that it should be very
traceable you know in basically if
they're surprised by something coming
along it should be because they weren't
paying attention not because we live in
some ivory tower and then threw
something over the wall and then they
had to catch and go geez I guess we're
gonna have to do something with this
like that's that's just not a thing in
effort and that's something that is a
core tenant that we want to continue
okay and another core tenet F sharp has
ubiquitous and feature full tools you
can use all of the greatness with
f-sharp IDE tooling in your environment
of choice you don't have to use Visual
Studio you don't have to use Windows you
can do it where you want to okay and
then F sharp is developed openly and in
collaboration with the community the
last two versions of the link so the
forthcoming 14.5 and then the one that
we're on right now the current version
of F sharp has multiple features that
were done by community members and then
other features even though they were
implemented by Microsoft employees had a
lot of work you know not just in github
comments but you know in actual when it
was a language suggestion and you know
just discussion and you know hashing out
the various various problems that could
arise with using something what are the
trade-offs what are the use cases how is
this potentially useful you know helping
us draft rfcs and you know noticing hey
this thing that you're designing maybe
you should say it a little differently
or something like that that's that's the
way it's all done and this is something
that we wish to continue still so now
comes the hopefully not too crazy part
where I compare f sharp to other
functional programming languages because
you're in the FB track this is not the F
sharp track despite the fact there's a
whole bunch of shark box right but that
there are other functional languages out
there and despite the fact that I want
you to use F sharp I don't want you to
only use F sharp I want you to check out
other languages too and evaluate them
based on what you prior
Tai's but I'm gonna talk a little bit
about some pros and cons with three of
the popular other popular functional
programming languages and hopefully they
make sense and hopefully they resonate
and if not well you can tell me
afterwards so Haskell this is like the
granddaddy of functional programming
languages this is the FP language if you
want to bend your mind for sure let's
talk about some cons of F sharp vs.
Haskell so first of all we have less
language features some people may say
that's a feature other people won't it
just kind of depends on who you are but
we do have strictly less language
features all right we lack many of the
higher-order abstractions that are
possible in a scale with different
languages especially with different
language extensions like I don't know if
anybody's played around with liquid
haskell at all but that stuff blows your
mind right and there's just there's
there's not even a concept of like a
land extension inside of f-sharp there's
no way for you know one person in
research to sort of say oh I'm gonna
just really go to town on this you know
aspect of category theory and then
incorporate it into the language and
then have you be able to opt into it on
an ad-hoc basis right that's something
that you can do in Haskell that you
cannot do in F sharp today and if that's
something that you value and something
that you want then you may find yourself
not enjoying a sharp as much as Haskell
alright and then lastly and I mean this
earnestly and I think it's not something
that we can particularly overcome I
think Haskell is strictly better when it
comes to bind like just just blowing
your mind like if you want to just blow
up your brain and then scrape your brain
off the walls afterwards because this
thing totally changed the way you
thought about programming Haskell was
probably the best thing was to do so you
can absolutely do this in F sharp too
but if you want to go way further you
should go with Haskell for sure alright
and if that means for some people that
is the goal of learning FP is you want
to blow your mind a little bit and
Haskell is the best way to do that but
there are some advantages to using F
sharp over Haskell number one we have
consistent idioms and code style so if
you look up how to solve a particular
problem in Haskell you're gonna find a
tremendous amount of answers which are
probably all great ways to solve it but
that doesn't necessarily mean those ways
are going to help you out because they
may depend on a particular concepts that
will require a week's worth of learning
for you to be able to even understand
how the code
or maybe the thing that they showed
won't work for you anymore because
Haskell does binary ins you know they do
breaking changes sometimes between minor
versions of the compiler and this is
something that we just don't do in F
sharp or rather if we do it's considered
a bug or an accident and it gets fixed
we don't we don't break things
intentionally and so the intention is
that five years down the road code that
you've written today should still be
able to work with a future version of
the language and a future version of the
tools this is not something that's true
in the Haskell world and it's something
that if you want to go that route you
need to be prepared for we have
commercial tooling and support from
Microsoft and jetbrains period right
there's commercial tooling and support
from two different companies and it runs
on officially supported platforms right
there's an official SDK for dotnet for
adjure an official SDK for AWS right
that's f-sharp runs on net there you go
right there are no official SDKs for
Haskell on any of these platforms or
things like that or maybe there's some
community driven thing but it's not
supported by a company that actually
owns that platform if that's something
that that matters for you well that's an
advantage of F sharp F start vs. closure
it's great I actually did my college
projects in closure so actually I really
love closure as a language I encourage
you to check it out despite what I say
there are there are some console this is
where closure does better than F sharp I
think an F sharp there's a lot more
ceremony for working with data
Clojure is one it's a dynamic language
so it's incredible
for just slurping up data of any shape
and turning it into a map like the
closure map type is amazing and if you
want to do a similar thing in F sharp
like as I showed earlier you have to do
these different type declarations and
there's different types of types and
maybe you have to blend a little bit of
oo with it if you want to express it
quite succinctly that's a lot more
overhead than just doing something in
closure and if your primary job is to do
something like that then maybe closure
is a bit more appropriate it's hard to
say this is something you're gonna have
to try it on your own and evaluate f
sharp also has no macro support the way
the closure does so I mean if you if
you've ever experimented with macros in
a language they're pretty cool and they
can allow you to express things
very succinctly and well on the other
hand sometimes they can be a little okay
Candace Peschel II knew people who
aren't familiar with macros usually have
no idea what they're doing
but if that's something that you value
then this is a distinct advantage the
closure has over f sharp we have nothing
like closure to spec it's a relatively
new thing that came out it's it's it's
like venturing into the realm of
refinement types like you get with the
dress and and F star which are other
interesting functional programming
languages but it's it's in a dynamic
setting and it's basically saying well
you can write this specification of the
way the date the incoming data for
something should look and properties of
that data and then you can just write
code that wires that up and it all
basically just works and then you get
you can like customize errors and stuff
if it doesn't if the data doesn't look
the way that you specified it to it's
it's pretty great and we don't we don't
have something like that so that's
that's something to keep in mind but
there are some pros f-sharp over closure
so static nominal types are pretty easy
to write maintainable code with I think
sometimes at least in the functional
programming community people can get a
little overzealous about how nominal
type you know there's all these amazing
type stuff but like fundamentally just
having static types and just having a
nominal type system takes you a really
long way and it's really easy to modify
code because it's just a really direct
one-to-one mapping between I say I am
this thing I am defined as not this
thing therefore it is a compiler error
period right if I say that I am the
thing and then you know it's defined as
this thing that's just what it is it's a
very straightforward thing it's a rather
underrated feature if you will and this
is you know closures that I'm a dynamic
language so it doesn't have static
typing and doesn't have you know this
nominal type system that you can use F
sharp has comprehensible error messages
anybody who's played with closure for
anything serious knows that the error
messages are basically just dumps of
stacktrace they're no fun that's
something that closure community has
been complaining about for a long time
hasn't really been addressed that well
it's it's good error messages are really
hard and but it's something that you
know we get from the type system that
we're in
and also something that the f-sharp
community in particular has really
sought to improve over the past year and
a half or so two years a sort of thing
and having error messages where not only
does it you know very succinctly and
accurately tell you what the problem is
but it can sometimes also offer
suggestions based on information that
the compiler holds at that time like if
you're trying to do something with an
enumeration where you've defined a
certain number of cases you know an
f-sharp enum and you only account for
one of those cases well you can get a
warning that will tell you hey you're
not accounting for all the cases by the
way here's an example of some of the
cases that you're not accounting for
that's that's just something that we
have in our error message which is it's
pretty important another thing is that
evolution of the f-sharp language is
entirely in the open if you follow some
of the folks in the closure community
there can be sometimes a sense that it's
a bit of an ivory tower sort of
situation in terms of what happens in
the language and then stuff gets thrown
over the wall it's it's up to you to
interpret kind of the level of truth to
that but I mean it's something that you
can read about pretty easily this is
this is just not something that we that
we do in F sharp one of our fundamental
tenants is open completely entirely open
collaboration with the community from
suggestions to what the language should
be to RFC's specifying exactly what's
going to be implemented to the actual
implementation and and you know feedback
loops all across that whole thing that's
just the way that f-sharp evolves and
finally I sharp versus Scala so this is
actually a bit of a blending of the
first two really so some of the cons we
have less language features than Scala
Scala has a whole bunch of language
features sometimes you know they're not
necessarily what people would enjoy the
most but they exist lots of features
there more specifically this is I mean
this is a more specific version of the
you know lacking higher ordered things
but there's no higher kind of types this
is something that in F sharp and this is
something that a lot of scholar
developers view as essential to being
able to abstract stuff there are ways
that you can abstract where you can
basically abstract the same way in F
sharp that you know you don't see me you
don't have to
simulate hire counter types but you can
get that same level of abstraction just
perhaps through a different vehicle and
this is something that sometimes people
may not feel comfortable with because
they may want to use you know a higher
kind of type system to represent certain
abstractions and if that's not possible
or the way to do it is different than
than what they're used to that could
potentially be seen as a con it's just
that's something we have they're also
really honestly an important one we
there's no native ocker spark support
now there is a connect and there are
alternatives to spark on net and those
will get you very far Aqua Net is a
fantastic open source country open
source project I really recommend trying
it out but at the end of the day akka
and spark are these two really big very
well used frameworks that were built in
Scala by you know consulting companies
in the scala community and that's just
where it originated and if that's
something that your business needs to do
or if they say these are the frameworks
that we want to use Scala is probably
the best choice for doing that but well
you know there's some pros similar to
the Haskell thing we have consistent
idioms and code style there's there's at
least from my vantage point there's
quite a split in the scala community
between the super functional group the
people who love category theory and and
maybe they want to lift some of the
amazing stuff out there into their
programming and they want to model their
systems as mathematically as possible
and I mean that in a very good way right
and then there's another part of the
community that just wants to do
object-oriented programming with Scala
with a little bit of functional
sprinkled in and they don't care about
any of that stuff and that's there's a
very distinct split and so if you want
to figure out how to do something
because you're learning the language or
you know maybe you're it's a massive
language so you're gonna always be
learning well you may see two vastly
different approaches to the problem and
and it may not be clear which one you
need to take and why and it can also
lead to big splits and larger code bases
as well because you may have one team
that prefers one style and the other
team that prefers the other and it kind
of bifurcates you know the system that
you're working in and that can be a big
burden and that's just not really that
big of a problem in F sharp I mean you
like any programming language you can
use it to all hell and you can just do
you know all sorts of crazy stuff but
the fundamentals of F start programming
are going to be common just about
everywhere again we don't do binary or
source breaking changes this is if that
exists it's a bug or you know an
accident or something it's something
needs to be fixed you know the new
version of Scala that's coming out I'm
glad that they're doing it but it's
gonna have source braking changes so
like that's I'm glad that they're
upfront about it but hey that's
something that we just don't do you know
and again there's commercial tooling
support for Microsoft and jetbrains
there actually is in a JetBrains Scala
plugins it's actually pretty good I
recommend trying it out
don't let this discourage you from
trying this language so I can try out
everything that I did I showed here and
then again we do transparent and open
evolution of the language so this has
also been a complaint that I've seen
which is that you know there's this
ivory tower in which something gets
innovated and then it gets thrown over
and then you know the community kind of
does what they can with it and so as a
result they've built some incredible
libraries that transform the way that
you program in Scala but that has been
done somewhat in response to the
language not evolving the way that they
wanted it to evolve and that's formed
its own community and then its own split
in the ecosystem that's just not
something that we have in F sharp and
that's something that we want to avoid
because we want to be transparent and
open about everything that we do and we
want to do everything to a point where
you know not everybody is going to agree
with how we move how F sharp the
language moves and what we do is it but
we at least want there to be a
reasonable compromise for everyone so
they say yeah okay you know this wasn't
exactly what I wanted but I can still
work with this that's that is our goal
and that's what we seek to do so kind of
just F sharp versus X I mean there's
lots of different languages I don't have
enough time to you know talk about every
single one it's we have our own guiding
principles and our own approach to
things and they're fundamentally
different from other languages and that
may appeal to you right we're not
universally better than any language and
we're not universally worse than any
language we just have our own way of
doing stuff and that's that's just
something that you know hopefully it
appeals to you if you try it out it's
pretty damn great if you do though most
people who try F sharp usually end up
really loving it
so one thing that I want to leave you
with if you try f sharp you decide you
like it
but you're like oh geez how do I get
this into the workplace well here's your
elevator pitch for your boss you can
tell them that Microsoft told you this
the first point is f-sharp is a stable
consistent powerful and commercially
supported language right those are those
are some checkboxes that businesspeople
like to see so you can you can have that
there and as ubiquitous and feature full
tools right you may have a developer on
your team who doesn't want to use
Windows in Visual Studio and that's
totally fine there's there's nothing
preventing them from using you know F
sharp with the same solution that you
are if you're using Windows in Visual
Studio like you can work together and
there's there's not going to be a big
issue there all right F sharp is a part
of dotnet and Azure and it helps drive
their innovation through a lot of
different ways and this is this is just
it's just it right and then F sharp has
a healthy and active open-source
community this is I think something
that's increasingly important for
choosing text axe in the future because
you want to have you know and say you
have a particular tooling vendor or
library vendor or something like that
and they don't quite do what you need at
the time you can find an open source
library that does what you need and
maybe it doesn't quite do everything you
can contribute back and things like that
that's something that we have in F sharp
and that's something that's really
important so I think I'm gonna leave you
with that hopefully this was a
convincing enough talk to go try out F
sharp on your own and if you've tried it
out before but you thought you said oh
you know I don't know if I could get it
to work and in my environment or
something like that give it a go again
you have your elevator pitch for your
boss to convince them that F sharp is
worth it because that's usually the
number one problem that people have
actually it's it's that they try it they
love it but then they can't convince
their boss who's you know doesn't want
to see change in the code base for some
reason or something like that
well this is something you can do thank
you very much for your time and yeah
[Applause]